brita seuil est bon je ne vous dérange
pas trop pas dit vous avez vraiment très
très gentil car je sais vous avez une
journée de tournage particulièrement
fatigante
j'aimerais vous poser une question
brigitte bardot c'est la première fois
que vous travaillez sur la direction de
clouzot clouzot n'a pas la réputation
d'être un metteur en scène commode
est-ce que lorsque vous avez appris que
vous deviez faire un film avec lui vous
n'avez tout de même pas eu une certaine
appréhension je le désirais pourrait-on
savoir pourquoi vous dire qu'elle est
l'actrice qui ne désirent pas tourner un
film sur la d accents blues ou blessés
uniquement sur le plan professionnel du
métier renseigne en ce qui concerne les
rapports d'interprète à metteur en scène
c'est à dire les rapports humains je
n'ai pas d'appréhension je vous ai ans
raconte tellement de choses sur tout le
monde qui sans fausse que je me suis
aperçu que c'était une chose de postes
de plus c'est un damné que monsieur
clouzot n'est pas du tout le tyran
contrat qu'il est au contraire
enfin moi je m'entends très bien avec
lui point de vue tournage c'est
formidable où tout se passe bien donc ce
plateau secret ce plateau défendu il n'y
est un plateau sans histoire un plateau
secret parce que quand ya trop de monde
on peut pas travailler bien vous savez
ça
sans ça ça ne serait pas un plateau
secret si au lieu de travail et nous
nous amusions vous seriez là tous les
jours oui personnellement ça ne me
déplairait pas croyez le magnen plaît
bon alors en ce qui concerne le travail
tout se passe bien c'est donc un plateau
sans mystère la vérité peut être montré
toute nue si j'ose dire sans jeu de mots
sont des états unis n'est pas tout non
certains le déplorons peut-être
peut-être enfin n'est pas tout est ce
que vous arrivez vous à faire une
différence entre l'actrice et la femme
se désirent trouve n'êtes pas un peu
vous même victime de ce mythe d
oh non je ne sais pas qui a créé le
mythe bb en tout cas je suis ravi d'être
à 8
je suis mais je n'y crois pas
particulièrement
ça nous a absolument pas impressionner
pas me dire puisque ça pour
m'impressionner
alors s'il en faut plus que ça de quoi
vous ne le serai jamais on a envie
d'être gentil avec un léger temps que ça
me fait bien plaisir que vous me disiez
ce changement le thème change mais à ce
propos justement à ce propos on a dit on
a écrit beaucoup de choses sur vous vous
lisez vous entendez bien sûr on a parlé
de votre vie privée personnellement
j'estime qu'on n'avait pas à le faire
mais puisqu'on l'a fait est ce que vous
pourriez pas profiter de l'occasion qui
vous est offerte aujourd'hui pour mettre
les choses au point une fois pour toutes
si j'ai trouvé ça absolument écoeurant
parce que tout ce qui a été créé 17 ans
derniers faux et que ça rejaillit sur la
santé de jacques et que je trouve que
des mensonges qui arrive à mettre hors
jeu la santé d'un homme c'est vraiment
de choses épouvantables
j'espère qu'il va bien maintenant qu'il
se remet oui en fait je ne suis pas là
pour parler de lui mais ça c'est quand
même une chose qui ne devrait pas être
permise même si on est une actrice on ne
doit pas être en butte à ce genre de
choses vous avez raison et j'espère je
souhaite ardemment que cela soit terminé
un dernier mot comment va nicolas rami
que la va très bien renvoyer ravit bien
dans une première site